[Musique]
on retrouve ollier bachand au centre
ville de montréal olivier bonsoir
l'autre grosse dépense en temps des
fêtes c'est la nourriture et la hausse
des prix des aliments est quand même
importante cette année olivier
oui le prix la nourriture gérald qui a
bondi d'environ 4% en un an mais pour
certains aliments vous allez le voir sur
le tableau s'est encore plus élevé les
prix de la viande par exemple ont
augmenté de près de 10% on a regardé
pour la volaille parce que qui dit temps
des fêtes 10 dead alors à ce niveau là
c'est une hausse d'environ 9 % de pib
qu'une bond de 20% petite baisse pour
les fruits et légumes le prix des
boissons alcoolisées lui a augmenté
d'environ 1% la remporte tout de même
très inquiet cette année mais comment
faire pour recevoir la famille dans un
contexte d'inflation alimentaire comment
faire pour préparer un bon repas même si
on ne veut pas casser son petit cochon
on vous propose ce soir gérald deux
menus pour les budgets modestes et vous
allez voir si possible de bien manger
sans trop dépenser excellent merci
comment impressionner ses invités à noël
sans trop se souffler et sans se ruiner
j'en ai l'eau à la voix nous avons
demandé conseil à l'animatrice de
l'émission savourer la nutritionniste
geneviève o'gleman via un menu à 5
dollars environ par personne
on commence avec des canapés aux pommes
et au prosciutto ensuite on a des belles
cuisses de poulet au romarin et aux
canneberges servi avec une purée de
pommes de terre et un broccolini puis on
termine avec des biscuits des biscuits
enfin des pistes des sablés au chocolat
comment on fait pour en arriver à un
menu de 5 $ par portion le menu de 5 $
est basé sur la simplicité on choisit
des ingrédients de base la cuisse de
poulet le c'est très très très peu cher
on la rend festive le nom qu on lui
ajoute des saveurs du temps des fêtes le
romarin la canneberge l'érable puis on
la sert sur une purée ça peut être une
purée de pommes de terre très simple et
on peut élever la purée à un autre
niveau en ajoutant du penne ou de choux
fleurs pour la rendre un peu plus des
gangs est jamais bon
nous a aussi concocté un menu un peu
plus dispendieux on peut aller avec un
menu à environ 15 de leur personne on
commence avec un griffon d'or aux
oignons confits et aux pommes ensuite on
peut enchaîner avec un beau gigot
d'agneau aux pommes une plaque de
légumes racines une belle salade aux
figues et à la courge et on termine avec
un gâteau bound au chocolat et aux
canneberges alors que les cuisses de
poulet sont autour de 6 $ le kilo on
passe à 30,40 dollars le kilo pour
l'agneau c'est une viande je pense va
être très très très apprécié et ensuite
on construit le menu avec des
accompagnements qui sont moins coûteux
que
la fameuse bûche j'ai fait mon
c'est très coûteux on a dans les
pâtisseries les épiceries fines des
bûches autour de 50 60 des x 70 dollars
alors que mon gâteau bonne au chocolat
et aux canneberges qui est très élégant
revient à environ 20 dollars pour
l'ensemble des 12 portions la première
chose eh bien il va falloir préparer la
farce une erreur le fait de partir en
peur de voir trop grand de penser à la
grosse dingue elle est non seulement
coûteuse intimidante mais le risque de
la critique est soit trop cuite sèche
pas ses juteuses il est présent puis ça
devient stressant pour la personne qui
reçoit tout
[Musique]
ici on pense aux noëls d'antan de nos
grands parents de nos arrière grands
parents c'était très très modeste le
repas était très simple mais ce n'est
pas moins festive pour autant il est
parti seul vélo en les rigodons la danse
la fête
c'est pas le prix de notre menu qui
compte c'est le temps passé avec les
gens qu'on aime c'est de se retrouver on
peut trouver toutes les recettes des
fêtes de geneviève o'gleman a savouré
points c'est à barres obliques noël
laisse beaucoup et joyeuses fêtes et
joyeuse frais
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne et si r d